if you're a chronic career Hopper
usually it's because you have one of two
problems either you don't know how to
properly identify opportunities and so
you keep picking the wrong thing or the
wrong place to work because you're not
looking at other things so you might be
like well this place offered me $17 more
a year and so even though these people
seem really nice and these people seem
terrible I'm going to take these people
so you might have a terrible
decision-making process the other is
that you just have unrealistic
expectations of work which is that it's
going to be a fairy land and you're
going to enjoy every single part of it
and that's just not true like no one
loves when 100% of everything they do